Speaker 1: Seemingly not a single day goes
by that the crisis of information handling
under the former administration is exposed,
that being even worse than we imagined and
remember the back story and the framing here.
Hillary Clinton in 2015 and 2016, we were told,
cannot be president. We can't trust her
as president. Why? Well, private email,
improper handling of secret information. Sensitive
information is just not trustworthy. And then what
did we have? Yeah. Trump spills secrets to a
Russian spy recruiter in the Oval Office and
of Trump's family. Ivanka and Jared Kushner using
private email for White House Business. Oh no.
And then Trump's ripping up presidential records
in the in the White House. And people are running
in and trying to tape them together. Trump
is sending documents and burn bags to the
Pentagon to be incinerated. But Hillary,
we couldn't have trusted. And then we find
out. Trump was flushing documents down the White
House toilet. It was getting clogged and staff
was having to come in to, you know, start plunging
away to try to unclog Trump's toilet from all the
documents. And then the National Archives has
had to go to Mar a Lago to take back documents
from Trump that he improperly took from the White
House. And it turns out now that it wasn't just
documents generically that are at the heart of
this mishandling crisis involving Donald Trump.
We now know guys that this includes classified
and documents marked as top secret. There is
a new explosive report from The Washington
Post. Some Trump records taken to Mar a Lago
clearly marked as classified, including
documents at top secret level. This was not
previously reported, The Washington Post
writes. Some of the White House documents
that Donald Trump improperly took Tamara Lago were
clearly marked as classified, including documents
at the top secret level. This is according to two
people familiar with the matter. The existence
of clearly marked classified documents in the
trove, which has not been previously reported,
is likely to intensify the legal pressure
that Trump or his staffers could face
and raises new questions about why the
materials were taken out of the White House.
It was unclear how many classified documents were
among those received by the National Archives.
Some bore markings that the information was
extremely sensitive and would be limited to
a small group of officials with authority to view
such highly classified information. The documents
were just sitting around at Mar a Lago, guys. The
markings were discovered by the National Archives,
which last month arranged to collect 15 boxes
from Trump's residence archive. Officials asked
the Justice Department to look into this, though
as of Thursday afternoon, FBI agents had yet to
review the material. It remained unclear whether
the Justice Department would launch a full fledged
investigation. The files were being stored in
a sensitive compartmented information facility,
while Justice Department officials debate
how to proceed. Like others in this story,
the people spoke on the condition of anonymity
to discuss a potential, potentially politically
sensitive matter. Now, the Trump position on
this is according to spokesman Taylor Budo,
which it's clear that a normal and routine
process is being weaponized by anonymous,
politically motivated government sources to
peddle fake news. No, no. The president taking
top secret documents to his house after no longer
being president is not a routine matter. It is not
a routine matter. And remember, again, that when
we think back to the Clinton era Bill Clinton now,
I mentioned this last week. Bill Clinton had a
national security adviser named Sandy Berger.
Sandy took four documents that he was not supposed
to have in his possession independently of,
you know, where they were supposed to be
stored. Sandy Berger was fined $50000.
He was given years of probation, and he
lost his license to practice law. Is there
no point at which there would be consequences for
this? And there's also another question, which is
why did Donald Trump even do this like
I? Trump's not really a sentimental guy,
so it's hard to imagine that he took talks
top secret documents for sentimental reasons.
Was he maybe thinking of these documents
as being in his hands as protecting him in
some way? It's mere speculation. Did he? I mean
being Trump? Did he think maybe he could sell
these documents for money at some point? Like,
it's all bizarre. And remember that the base of
all of Trump's campaign against Hillary
Clinton back in 2016 and even possibly
what put him over the top? Thanks to James
Comey's second press conference about Hillary
Clinton's emails. The whole premise was Hillary
can't be trusted with sensitive information.
Does anybody believe for a second that Hillary
would be flushing documents down her toilet,
clogging it and then calling down to maintenance,
saying, Bring the plunger? I've clogged the toilet
with documents again. Give me a break, guys,
give me a break. And this was the main reason we
weren't supposed to vote for Hillary Clinton. Will
there be consequences? I don't know. Jamie Raskin
believes there will be, and we'll cover that story
later on this week. I remain very, very skeptical.